regarding therapy I had a lot of benefit
from going to therapy for about two
years three years but I have the
suspicion that um therapy in Romania is
very different to what therapy is in the
US or Canada how was that for you yeah
it's interesting therapy in Romania is
probably a bottle of V kind of slap up
the side the
head no it was very
technical there was a lot of analysis
over um kind of statements that was
making and the kind of beliefs that I
was uh
holding and uh was it a male therapist
or a female one a female therapist
okay so you got benefit from a female
therapist in Romania interesting Okay
carry
on
um we got to the source of a lot of my
internal tension and I actually wanted
to work through it but 3 years then I
decided it was taking too long long and
I don't have 20 years to get all of this
fixed and I went in I went to Peru for
aaska and you solved everything in a
iasa
ceremony well I think I solved most of
the things that I wanted to solve and it
definitely got a huge benefit and as a
consequence um my life cleaned up
afterwards um but I I really wanted um
to get better and to fix some
things um question for you like how how
useful have you found psychedelics for
dealing with [__] iasa Soul
cybin well here's the thing um if you
have the
intent of fixing stuff so it's not just
recreational for you there's a lot more
benefit than just the
marginal benefit the benefit that you
get by just going through the motion
there were people there that um did the
same things that I did took the same
Doses and didn't exactly exactly get um
the same benefit or to the same
extent
um so psychedelics I think play they're
a very important
tool on your journey of fixing some
things for example one of the traumas
that I had was uh that because my mom
died when I was 10 I was missing the
female model in my life so my
relationships were kind of messy I was
avoidant and I couldn't connect with a
woman so like I was uh having sex but
there was no connection everything was
um black and white there was no color so
that only came very late in my
life
interesting well work for somebody at
least I mean I've done I've done
marriage counseling you know before and
that that was just a colossal waste of
time that just demonstrated to me that I
had married the wrong person didn't
solve anything remember if anything it
it it got me to the point of oh okay so
now I have more clarity faster and it's
time to untie the nut remember of
anyway
yeah sry 50 yeah I remember when Donnie
Brasco got out of marriage therapy in um
in the movie Donnie Brasco Johnny de
yeah yeah no just just just just to Echo
dr's point I went to see a female
therapist probably like 10 10 years ago
and you know I went in and I sat down on
her sofa and she goes you look
absolutely beaten she said and of course
naturally I was married and she encou
she encouraged me actually rich Cooper
advice she said you have a group of guy
friends and she said you know why don't
you join a drinking Club there's tons of
Irish Drinking clubs around so I did you
know that was that was literally she
said get a tribe get a tribe of man and
get drunk well yeah I
mean good did go do man stuff yeah but
um Ma you uh you mentioned some great
points yesterday in the chat about um or
about cooking and if you if you want to
discuss some of that I can drop a few
names and a few suggestions
one more thing that
like for me therapy was very educational
it was like uh hey okay let's see where
you are let's make an analysis of uh
what you're doing what you're saying
what you're thinking what you're
feeling uh okay we've done the analysis
let's work on this once you've done this
we can work on something else and move
forward and it was not like um yeah it
was like school like here's what you
need to do and now you go do it if you
don't do it you won't
improve excellent excellent points and
look going back to what you know drga
says and what I've noticed since I've
delved into a lot of stoic philosophy um
is the the reason why these these men
Zeno edus marus you know Plato why there
why are there names that roll off
people's tongues 2,000 years after they
died is because their wisdom is um
unbelievable and and yeah but it's it's
a lot of what I've noticed is a lot of
these you know people who are offering
therapy online advice nowadays are
literally just ripping off what these
guys are saying 200000 years ago and
repackaging it and sugarcoating it and
it you know like there's no real new
ideas and solutions the world today
they're just repackaged is all it is you
know they say that um what's the line
that advice is like a form of nostalgia
or something along that it's like it's
like fishing something out of the
garbage cleaning off the nasty parts and
then selling it for more than what it's
worth
but you will find that a lot of stuff
you hear echod from like you could turn
on Joel Austin do Phil any of these
people I can I can listen to these guys
and I'll see Marcus aelas pop up I'll
see all the great quotes from all they
just being
repackaged and it's uh you you know if
if you if you read this stuff
like it'll do you it'll do you a lot
more mental mental good than than some
of the stuff out there but you know you
run across someone technical like a
friend of mine's a he's an actual
psychiatrist he's an Asian guy Korean
and he's he's real solid guy and some of
the wisdom that dude drops about just
not giving a crap about stuff once you
get over 40 is probably some of the best
advice I
got yep people worry about stuff that
doesn't require a thought for the most
part
yeah you also have to keep in mind that
being a self-d learning by yourself is
not always the fastest way of dealing
with an issue like when you have
somebody else like a coach or what my
therapist was to me it's much easier to
know when the things that you think that
you've learned or integrated are
actually the things that you need or
maybe it was just a misinterpretation of
an advice or something that you read so
it's kind of important to work with a
professional I
think I look at I look at therapy and
therapists
as the same way I look at you know
personal
trainers
or yeah I think I think it's it's diffic
it's extremely difficult to find one
that knows what they're talking about
wants the best for you and doesn't want
to keep you sick so you're going to
continue to keep paying them year after
year after year um it's the reason why I
generally don't think men should be go
to therapy in
at least here in the US like the APA is
a a sham of an organization it's got
this feminist liberal W agenda it's
completely dominated by women in the US
I think it's like 80 plus percent of our
psychologist are are female um I think
men do better with more of a coaching
model than a therapy model and and
people will come after me people come
after me about this and say oh well
therapy is different for everyone but I
think when we talk about therapy we're
talking about talk therapy you go into
an office or you get on a zoom call now
in 20 23 and you lay in a Sha's lounge
and you talk about how you're feeling
and this and that and so the it's for a
lot of people for a lot of people that
do it it's this vicious cycle of I go to
the dock I talk about all my problems I
get to feel better because I don't have
other people to talk to because nobody
cares because I'm a man and then I leave
feeling better and then slowly over the
course of a week I feel worse and worse
and worse until it's Thursday again time
to go back for more therapy so it
becomes this
endless vicious cycle of just feelings
and so what I think
therapy doesn't do for the vast majority
of people especially the vast majority
of men it's not concerned with treating
the sickness it's concerned with
treating the symptoms it's about how
you're feeling it's not about the
underlying reasons that you're feeling
depressed or you're in bad moods all the
time or you have problems it's it's more
of how do you go it's you know men need
to change their lives and be more
satisfied with their lives well how do
you do that you get good at stuff you
know you get the body that you want you
get the women that you want you get the
money coming in that you want you know
and if most men would focus on taking
care of those three things I think first
and then if there was other stuff left
over I think look do I think there are
guys out there that have legit stuff
they need to unpack and and deal with
absolutely but do I think that the
average man
has is is depressed no I think think
they're just unhappy about their plight
and I think that they have a lot of work
to do and it's easier to be told by
somebody that you're special and that
your feelings matter than it is to have
somebody like us say shut up and do the
work and then say how you feel in a
year it's that humans are the only
species that sit down and talk about
[__] and pay to sit down in a closed
room on a couch to somebody that has a
degree framed to Mahogany on the wall
right it's like you know what did they
do a thousand years
ago well it up for a hunt you kept it in
house that's the thing you kept it in
the you kept it in house right you
didn't go share it with somebody else or
share it with a stranger no you took the
for a HT fig out
right right
here the kind of therapy that you guys
are talking about I would call that I
don't know psychological masturbation or
something perfect my therapy sessions
Prett were hard at some point I was
sweaty I was was exhausted by the time
the the meetings were done we did
hypnosis a few times and I just went
back home and I went to sleep it was a
lot of work it was not okay so what did
you do
today yeah I I I have to agree with you
on that but but but going back up to M's
point it is a business at the moment and
you can go through YouTube or your your
feed and there'll be ads popping up all
the time and they'll literally be
bombarding everybody telling them
there's something wrong with you you
need a therapist you
know it's it's like and you know that to
me is this is the what do you call the
light and light and fluffy coffee C you
know cotton candy type of therapy I I
I'm I'm broken just as MAF said I'm
special I need to be this but as you
said Dr and I know a couple of people
that have gone through stuff like like
you've gone through and they've like
it's literally like they've been in the
gym for three hours when they get
out yeah and if you really want to put
in the work and and and go ahead and
better
yourself um yeah again also I think
there's an issue and the big difference
like Romania is the next communist
country over here the entire Health Care
system is a lot different you don't get
prescribed pills just so that um I don't
know big Pharma companies can make money
off of you so there's not this entire
predatory system that what you wants to
keep you hooked on their services on
their products on
whatever doesn't exist here so it's not
like that yeah even with a therapist
they would work with you and if in three
months you don't get better and you
don't improve and you don't put in the
work they'll just quit you they'll tell
you like you don't want to do the work
go on find somebody else I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out